this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
in this video not only are we going to
compare
ipad os 14 versus 15 real world
performance
we're also going to see if apple fixed a
few important
issues with the m1 ipads thunderbolts
connector
for example we have super fast ssds that
are much
lower on the m1 ipads than the macbooks
both having the same thunderbolt ports
so hopefully they fix that
we're also going to do other tests such
as multitasking
ram stress tests with uh both running
ipad os 15 we have eight gigs on one
ipad pro
16 on the other to see if apple fixed
the five gigabyte ram
limitation that was imposed which was
very interesting hopefully they fixed
that but we're also going to
see how the battery life compares
between both these i have both at 100
right now we're gonna go ahead and
unplug them now the first thing that i'm
gonna do
is i'm going to go ahead and clear out
everything
from our memory and then we are going to
do a fresh restart
wow okay so about a second faster there
we have nothing
loaded into the ram and the first thing
that i want to do is run
geekbench 5. as you guys could see we
have eight gigs of ram on the one with
ipad os 15
16 with 14 but as we saw previously
that didn't make any sort of difference
actually eight gig was a little bit
faster
so let's go ahead and start out we will
run our cpu test
so it looks like the performance is
about the same
nothing changed that's actually good for
people that are using the beta
sometimes the performance could get
worse this in this case it is the same
let's go ahead and run a quick compute
benchmark testing out the graphics
and it looks like the graphics
performance is also almost
identical so let's go ahead and close
down our geekbench 5. the last benchmark
i want to do
is the wildlife extreme benchmark which
is going to max out the graphics card
we're going to see if there's any
frequency differences and it also pushes
the battery to see if we're gonna have
any differences between them and then
we'll move on to real world performance
alrighty and look at that we are seeing
some differences in performance here we
have
10 better than all of their scores which
i don't know what this is showing up
here with insane scores that doesn't
seem right this one's 13
but overall we have 28.6 frames per
second compared to 29.1
now we also are seeing a battery
difference already here we're at 95
battery compared to 97 but we're just at
the start we're gonna have to wait till
later
to see if that difference actually grows
or closes down now before we test the
real world performance differences let
me give a shout out to the sponsor of
this video
squarespace if you've been thinking
about upgrading or making a new website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go
you can make a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience
and it doesn't matter if you want a
portfolio a blog ecommerce or anything
else
you just choose from one of their great
templates and customize blocks of text
and images
it's incredibly simple it's affordable
nars have been running flawlessly for
years now
bringing in tons of traffic thanks to
its built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card needed by going to
squarespace.com
maxtec or by using the custom link down
below and when you're ready to launch
you can save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain so now
let us get into the first real world
test i'm going to connect
my sabrint ssd if you saw our ipad
comparison to the macbook pro it took
way longer to transfer on the ipad
and with that it also couldn't transfer
all the files which was really weird
let's see if it's actually going to work
this time and
nope look at that it cannot work because
it can't communicate with help or
application
let's go ahead and close all of this
just to make sure
we don't get any corruption we're going
to unplug it and plug it into
the ipad os 15 version and i really hope
that this was fixed all right look at
that thank you apple
you fixed something another thing with
ipad os
15 thankfully we're gonna redo that
transfer test which took
much longer on the ipad so it looks like
unfortunately even though i closed the
files out before unplugging the ssd
it still corrupted it and it will not
mount no matter what i do
hopefully this is just an issue with
ipad os 14 and it doesn't happen with
15. i'm gonna go get my mac
i have to run the first date on there it
takes about 10 minutes to fix it
and then i can get back to testing bam
it showed up
thankfully let's transfer that same file
like we did before
bam just got done there took exactly
one minute to transfer that 16 gig file
plugging into ipad os 15.
all right why is it not showing up we
seriously cleared out the files app all
right this is getting to be
ridiculous i've never had this issue on
my mac hopefully it's just ipad os
14 and i will talk about this in my
review if i
do still have this issue with the new
ipad os all right let's grab that same
file now that the drive is done
this time we actually have a progress
bar here
and it looks like based on the estimate
it still
is not running at the proper speed even
with ipad os
15. bam that's exact same time
one minute for ipad west 15 and
mac os is close to three times faster as
you guys can see by this graph
next we're gonna test out video
rendering in adobe premiere rush
when we first got the m1 ipads it was
actually slower than the 2020
ipad pro which is very interesting so
let's go ahead and open up this project
here and now let's export them this
is high quality 4k footage from sony
cameras
in a 4k project set to high bam
all right guys look at that it took two
minutes and 46 seconds with ipad os 14
and the a12z took 2 minutes and 31
seconds
but with ipad os 15 it took 2 minutes
and 10
seconds a big improvement that is 28
faster with ipad os 15. that is
fantastic
still not that much faster than the 2020
model
but let's go ahead and open up lightroom
mobile right here
we have 50 42 megapixel
raw images they are stored locally all
of these have a ton of color
corrections applied let's go ahead and
export these
looks like 14 was faster
just by a little bit looks like by eight
seconds we have three minutes over here
and three minutes and eight seconds with
ipad os 15. so why do we have that
difference well
maybe it's because with photo editing
it's mostly based on cpu with a little
bit of graphics
compared to video where it's the
opposite mostly graphics heavy or it
could also be the fact that this one has
eight gigs of ram compared to 16.
now what i'm gonna do is upgrade this 16
gigabyte model
to ios 15 as well and we're gonna get
into
our ram test and right before that check
it out we have 83
battery life with ipad s14 compared to
80
with ipad os 15. so a very small
difference there
a little bit more drainage with ipad os
15 at least the first
beta version all right guys both are an
ipad os 15 and we're gonna do the
ultimate
ram comparison now that both are updated
and what i'm really curious about
does 16 gig make it any faster if you're
using pro apps and i have the
ultimate test that i've never seen
anybody do before i also have an app
that i've never seen
anybody use and uh we are gonna find out
if apple got rid of that five gig limit
and
developers are actually limited they
want to be able to use more
with the new m1 that's eight or 16 gigs
of ram but they were capped
which is interesting so hopefully apple
fixed that we will find out if they did
let's go ahead and get started as a
reminder i have the eight gigabyte
version on the right hand side
and the 16 gigabyte version on the left
hand side so i just opened up 20 basic
apps things that just stay open in the
background when you use it i don't know
if you guys saw that this took a lot
longer to open up
the apple store than the 16 gigabyte
model did
i don't know if that's just the wi-fi or
maybe we had to wait for an app to get
removed
before doing so so let's just go ahead
and open up
our apps right here and let me go back
to the oldest one to see if it remained
open on the 8 gigabyte before we do
any actual performance test so let's go
ahead and open up photos
nope as you guys could see photos stayed
open maps has a lot of info stream maps
nope still open now i was wondering if
there's a way to see how much of the ram
is actually being filled up and check
this out guys
there's actually an app on the app store
that could show you
it's called smart memory right there and
just to show you guys i have
all of these apps opened up right here
so let's go ahead and see
how much ram is being used bam look at
that we have
92 filled up on the 8 gig version so you
actually get 7.2
geeks not eight because of formatting
but it looks like we're using five and a
half
uh gigs of active compared to eight on
here
meaning that even though here we're not
filled up on ram all the way we have
another
almost five gigs available we have all
this available
the eight gig model is using more ram
meaning that some of these apps that are
here
they are completely loaded up here
whereas on the ipad they might be in a
half state or something like that or it
might be loading it up fresh
from the memory but when we saw earlier
it loaded up extremely quickly
i didn't notice the difference so let's
see what other app is very difficult to
load up so far none of these are too
difficult
let's do stocks for example okay stocks
loaded up
really quickly there podcasts
okay that's very interesting that
they're loading up at the same time
where actual used ram is showing up as
5.6 gigs compared to 8.4
maybe something else with the system i'm
not sure but we haven't even pushed
these
that hard yet so let's go ahead and open
up some more applications
this time we're going to do more
difficult ones how about we do
imovie and i'm going to actually go into
a project here you can go ahead and
scrub around
get some of this stuff loaded up all
right and then let's go and open up
adobe lightroom we know this is a big
application professional application
i'll go ahead and switch through some of
these 42 megapixel raw images i have a
bunch of effects
and as you guys could see these are
identical both extremely fast
performance
and these are actually stored locally
these are not little proxy files
this is quicker than on my macbook all
right
now let's open up photoshop let's open
up this adobe
stock image this is a really high
quality
file jeez it's just so responsive next
let's open up
adobe premiere rush and let's grab this
project right here all right so far
still fairly smooth these this also has
effects loaded onto it
let's close that of course we have to
open up youtube because
while we're youtubers we love you to
watch a lot of it
let's play the best song in the world
you guys already know it's a classic
here
at max tech and with youtube premium
we're going to close this it's going to
continue playing
the audio in the background which is
important and before we run an
actual performance test with the ram
loaded up let's do
one final app we'll open up genjen
impact that is just
crazy difficult i mean it pushes these
tablets any machines
to their limits actually any tablet or
phone to their limits and now i'm gonna
go ahead and open up
lumafusion where we have a project open
up
that we are going to export this is
another difficult project we have
different
effects loaded up on here uh we have a
different slow motion for 4k
and we have some retiming to speed
things up before we export that let's
open up our memory app once again
and check that out guys the 16 gig
actually has more used 95.5
compared to 93.78 of the 8 gigs
so the 8 gig is definitely doing
something in the background to allow all
these apps to
still stay there or partially stay there
we'll be checking that out in a bit
so both of these are completely maxed
out right now we're gonna go ahead and
export these
to our files app we have the same exact
high quality 4k
settings here let's hit export they
pretty much ended at the same exact time
no difference um i didn't hit the timer
fast enough but that was faster than 55
seconds
um i'm gonna go ahead and just leave it
like this so the file is just sitting
there
waiting to be told where to be saved so
i'm gonna leave that
right there and how about right now
before we do the next export i want to
do adobe rush because as you guys saw
earlier
it was a lot faster 28 faster with ipad
os 15
than with 14 but let me go ahead and
open up chrome here
and let's get some tabs open and look at
that did you guys see that
it actually had that save from our last
time we did
this video i don't know if that was a
week ago week and a half ago all these
tabs
are saved of course they're not
pre-loaded in there but we have some
video ads that are auto playing
let's go to here that's actually kind of
cool it shows in black and white first
until it loads it to allow it to load
let's go to the next page it's almost
like a screen shot
just to show you what that was get our
next tab loaded all right there we go
how about we jump into safari as well we
have the weather channel here
still loaded no issues there ign usually
takes a good amount of room they have so
much different content on here and how
about i load up about 10 more tabs here
so we have call of duty mobile also
loaded up
just for good measure here let's go
ahead and go back to
lightroom over here everything's still
loaded up that is great
and how about we go ahead and export all
50 of these
images and i also have one very
interesting very tough test that's
really gonna
answer this question once and for all if
16 gigabytes is worth it
now that we have ipad os 15. so
after that we're going to run that test
look at that guys the performance is
still
exactly the same so
i'm not seeing any difference it's crazy
how fluid
and how responsive ipad os is even with
all of that loaded up in the background
alright guys no difference there at all
that is mind-blowing
all right so now let's just put this to
the final test
i have lightroom opened up right here
i'm also going to go
go ahead and open up adobe rush bam did
you guys see that actually adobe rush
had to be
reopened whereas on the 16 gig it didn't
alright this is gonna be the final test
as far as performance so we know now
that
if you have a ton of apps open multiple
high-end games
multiple professional applications you
export 4k video
you export high quality professional
photos right after that
then you go into another video editing
app it does have to be reloaded
it did load pretty quickly though in
premiere rush so yes we are finally
seeing
some difference we didn't before ipad
was 15 but i want to put this
to the final test as far as performance
so what we're going to do is we're going
to grab premiere rush
we are going to load it side by side
with lightroom oh do you guys hear that
or at least maybe not hear that
both ipads actually closed down youtube
or at least they paused it or saved it
because the video
stopped playing as soon as i went into
multitasking
on both of these so that was about equal
now
at this point what i'm going to do is
i'm going to go ahead
and select all these 50 images i'm going
to export these we're going to get
started there
now let's resize this and then we are
going to
grab this project here and let's go
ahead and export this as well
bam all right guys this is the ultimate
test
does extra ram give you extra
performance we saw in video editing it
didn't even with all those apps and
games in the background
we saw in photo editing it didn't how
about we're exporting both photos and
video at the same time the toughest
thing you could throw
on a tablet like this it is definitely
taking longer than before
and our video editing just got finished
up oh
okay i did not expect that part of it to
happen
let's wait just for these photos to
finish up that's taking a bit longer
bam one of them just got finished up
let's wait for the other one
and bam we are done
so the final results are the 16 gig
model
took four minutes and 48 seconds total
in the eight gigabyte model that one
took five
minutes to export so yes it did take
longer by a whole 12 seconds
honestly i have to say i was expecting
for a i was expecting a bigger
difference than that it's good to see
that premiere rush stayed open with all
those other apps open
but it only took a couple seconds to
reload but as far as actual performance
this is the toughest thing i think i
could throw at it especially on desktop
use a lot of ram lightroom uses a lot of
ram
we definitely know ram helps but with
ipad os
we're not seeing any difference now what
that really makes me wonder is did apple
remove that five gigabyte ram
limit like we had with ipad os 14
i know some developers were complaining
about that they said they want to give
more performance to their users
but they can't because it's limited to
five gigs of usage per app now
understand when the ipads were
you know they only had up to six or
maybe eight i think six was the top
um you know you're limited to five you
know they want a one gig cushion for
other background stuff
but in this case we have eight and we
have sixteen so let me go ahead and do
some research
all right guys so i did find a developer
online that said that five gig
limit is still there so apps
cannot go any faster they cannot use any
more so if you have 16 gigs
you can't just give each one eight gigs
or seven gigs or give one
up to eight and the other one can have
less have it use as much as it wants but
raise that cap
it would make sense to at least raise it
till set to seven since this one has
eight gigs
or maybe if you have a 16 gig model
allow it to go higher
but it's still limited exactly the same
to when we had
six gigs of ram on our ipad pros last
year so i guess the only real benefit of
having that extra ram that you're forced
to pay for
is just having extra apps not close
themselves off
in the background so how about we do
that that's going to be the final test
let's see if youtube
reopens bam youtube is still open on
both like i said it did pause
automatically when i went to do that how
about we go
and take a look at call of duty
all right both were open let's do
lumafusion
check that out still open on the 16 gig
took us a couple seconds to reload it on
the 8 gig model but actually reloaded
right back to where we were at almost
like it saved it to the
to the ssd or to the memory let me open
up smart memory here we actually aren't
using up all the eight gigs at this
point
uh we are using 3.45 where so we still
have 800 free
where here we have 2.5 gigabytes free
how about the next thing we'll open up
is photoshop
in the first time i do this video with
both using ipad os 14
the 16 gig actually closed photoshop
where the 8 gig didn't
let's see what happens now wow
both of them are actually open so i
decided to keep photoshop
open but not lumafusion how about
gentian impact this is a huge game
just like i expected still open on 16.
we have to
reload on the 8 gig model and this game
does take a while to load
so that is where it's nice to be able to
just jump right back in
let's check out imovie wow actually on
both
about our photos app maps
reloaded on both i don't know if you
guys saw that let's jump back into
safari
alright guys did you see that safari
actually has to reload
this page here where on the 16 gig model
it did not let's take a look at some of
these other pages oh
amazon did have to reload let's check
out a tv app
open on both apple store it looks like
the apple apps stay open i don't know if
that's just by design
because apple wants them to stay open or
what but let's check out the app store
it looks like both of them reloaded
there and let's open up chrome
okay looks like chrome
might have stayed open oh this one just
had to reload or it's just extremely
fast at reloading certain things
there you go guys you can see a couple
these tabs did have to reload
but it is incredibly quick how fast
things reload other than gentian impact
which takes about four or five seconds
and then now let's just go back to the
ultimate craziest one
just for the finale here where's our 4k
professional video editing and the raw
photo editing
at the same time right here bam
look at that you got two pro apps i mean
adobe rush
it's not really pro to edit but it does
give you full high quality
video which that part of it the
processing and exporting is pro
you saw it stayed open here where here
we had to reload
both of them and in this case this is
still ready to save because i actually
didn't save these files maybe there was
all be different if i saved them
they're literally sitting there in the
ram ready to save
which actually probably made the whole
multitasking thing different because it
takes a lot more room without file just
sitting there
not being saved to storage taking up ram
so but like i said that was the ultimate
stress
test for ram i've never seen anybody do
it this difficult
pushing eight gigs and 16 to the limit
as far as performance
barely any difference no difference
unless you're exporting two pro apps at
once photo and video 4k and 42 megapixel
raw
and even then the difference was 12
seconds and the biggest difference
you'll see
is if you're going this extreme yes
the 16 gig will keep some things
open but as far as that five gig ram
limit apple has not
changed it and performance from ipad was
14 to 15
yes it definitely got better in certain
things um but
as far as transferring with our ssd that
is still slow
still waist lower than the macbook pro
which is
quite unfortunate but at least we do
have some of those improvements and some
of the folders that would just straight
up wouldn't transfer
are now transferring that is good so
thank you guys for watching if you guys
want to see the full review
of these new m1 ipad pros with all the
info that we gathered
our personal thoughts make sure you
click that circle above to subscribe
and that way you'll help us reach 1
million subscribers before the end of
the year that'd be amazing check out one
of those videos over there that's been
max and i'll see you in the next video